hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible and super complicated game uh
from defeat a candidate's tournament
2022 it's the second round and it's uh
rihard rapper versus alireza firujan
it's a really wild game features a great
opening great middle game and just a
spectacular endgame that no one could um
calculate to its fullest uh you know
with all the time in the world uh so we
have quite a lot to enjoy here let's
dive straight into it rapper has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 we
have c5 by alireza uh knight to f3 pawn
to d6 and d4 striking in the center uh
sorry about that uh we have c captures
on d4 and now uh not knight captures on
d4 which is probably the most common
move in chess there is no move i believe
played more than knight captures on d4
uh in in pretty much any opening on move
three uh but rather he goes for queen
captures on d4 and this is uh extremely
rare especially in top level chess the
checkover variation uh also known as the
hungarian variation as uh rapport is
hungarian so he's probably making a
little joke here in the candidates but
also uh it just means that he has it
prepared extremely well so yeah we're
not going to have the usual stuff with
knight captures on d4 uh it's alireza to
move so knight to c6
uh you play this pretty much uh
automatically you play this in bullet
you play this in classical you play this
in the candidates it's just grabbing a
tempo
as the queen on d4 is attacked but not
really as bishop to b5 pins the knight
and here alireza says all right make
your intentions known with the bishop do
you want to give up the bishop pair
early on or
what's happening here so bishop captures
on c6 this is the best move we have b
captures and the now pawn to c4 rapport
says all right um you get the bishop
pair uh but i get full control over the
d5 square my queen is nicely centralized
on d4 and there is no way to kick it
away uh from there just yet so here we
have e5 uh kicking it away from there
immediately but
this comes with a price you've further
weakened the d5 square and you're not to
have let's say e6 and pawn to d5 in the
future to make some sort of a central
breakthrough so queen to d3 and not
knight to e7 knight to f6 also is
popular here knight to e7
uh a little less but of course uh um uh
well very sure that alireza has this
prepared in case someone actually plays
this line and here uh rapport plays the
move that duda played yesterday against
him and it um
was incredibly difficult for him to
defend and that is pawn to c5 and this
just means that uh you're gonna weaken
the d6 square and now uh probably uh
black will be left with an isolated a
pawn and an isolated c pawn uh so here
at knight the g6 ball it is a c captures
on d6 we have queen captures and e6 and
here we have a queen trade captures
captures and there are some games where
castles was played but here rapper plays
bishop to e3 and it is now as of move 12
that we have a completely new game so
what is a rapport's idea here why did he
uh trade queens so early why did he give
up the bishop pair so early uh he must
have something uh exquisite prepared
here uh and okay alert is a place a5 he
wants to play bishop to a6 and prevent
rapper from castling
castles immediately and pawn to f6 now
just strengthening the e5 pawn
rook to c1 uh going after the pawn here
so this is basically all it is only
weakness he has the isolated apon the
isolated c pawn and it might be a bit
problematic for him to defend them so
rook to a6 we have knight beat to d2 and
now bishop to e6 we have knights to e1
re-maneuvering the knights to d3 uh king
to f7 preparing to bring the other rook
into the game and knight to d3 we have
rook to d8
uh and king to f1 you have to bring the
king into the game as our good friend uh
tara says uh in the quote above the
board uh bishop to b4 making some uh
some problems for for uh rapper but not
really we have to kink the e2 and now
knight to h4 going after the g2 pawn so
first knight captures on b4 a captures
on b4 and just pawn to g3 with knight
back to g6 and the bishop to c5 so it's
not much but rapport is definitely
asking some questions here how are you
defending the b for pawn uh already says
just rook to b8 and now pawn to a3
challenging the the the b for pawn b
captures on a3 and now rook captures an
a3 and now how do you
how do you go about this if you just
capture on a3 uh then b captures on a3
and you start bringing the knight into
the game and the problem is you have a
dark square bishop and the pawn promotes
on a light square so you're going to
have one um a piece less that to try and
promote this pawn with uh it might not
be
such a problem for alireza to defend
this so instead we have rook beat the a8
by alireza uh he he could go for this
but um he probably thinks that this will
uh that he will maybe have
greater chances of maybe playing for
more than a draw with this so knights to
c4 and the bishop captures on c4 with
check rook captures on c4 and now knight
to f8 he starts bringing this knight
into the game we have rook to b3 now
rapport says i might be interested in
going for rook to b7 check
but just knight to e6 not um worried
about that rook to b7 check king back to
g8 and now bishop back to e3
we have rooked a b8 and now pawn to f4
uh so still uh the pawn is now under on
the b file alireza with the pawn on the
c file both of them isolated pawns uh
it's a pretty pretty equal position uh
who will utilize the bishop or knight
better so here knight to d4 with check
bishop captures we have pawn captures
and king to d2 so the bishop and knight
will not be utilized did they get traded
off and now it's a it's a rook and pawn
end game and here we have rook to a1 uh
interestingly rook to a1 loses the game
uh for alireza and it's not easy to see
why but um
it's
it just is so here you have to play uh
something like h6 and just wait wait and
see what that part will do
the problem with this rook to a1 move is
that if played to perfection you can win
this with white and here rapper goes for
rook captures on c6
which gives him a past b pawn but
alireza will now start gobbling up the
king side pawns we have rook seat the c7
now threatening the g7 pawn and rook
captures an h2 with check king to d3 and
now pawn to g6 the h7 pawn is defended
uh but rapper just creates a pass pawn
of his own pawn to e5 we have f captures
f captures and now rook to h3 going
after rook captures on on g3 and this is
where things could go very wrong for
rapport or where things could go very
very um uh well for rapport so uh what
would you play here it's uh
it's such an interesting game i could
make any uh
moment basically a pause the video a
moment um uh so
let's use this one uh you are playing
against alireza here what would you play
here feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning idea for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on going for the
obvious rook to g7 check as that wins
the game on the spot but we are going to
discuss why because in the game rapper
played king to e4 which seems like a
move that only improves your position
because an active king is what wins the
end game that's kind of the rule
but here it just doesn't uh because
after rook the g7 check the these are
your options if you go kink to f8 you're
just gonna get checkmated the idea is
after rook b to f7 check king the e8
we're going to play e6 and there's no
defense against rook to g8 uh checkmate
yeah you can give a few checks but we're
going to be able to hide hydra king
behind something and that's
just just gonna be completely winning so
instead after rook the g7 check you have
to play king to h8 and now the point is
uh rook to d7 that's how you win this
and now of course we're going to capture
this with check
we're going to do this at some point so
we might do it right away now we're
going to play king captures on d4 now
alireza loses the past d-pawn and now
after rook to g4 check king c5 rook to
c8 to check we're going to play king to
d5 and now let's say rook to h4 because
the h7 pawn is hanging
pawn to e6 uh rook to e8 of course okay
not pawn to e7 because then we allow the
king back into the game but now we start
pushing the pass b pawn rook to h5
checking v6 and now of course you will
be winning this uh and that's uh that
that's uh that's the reality of the
position however after rapper's uh king
to e4 it is much much harder to play
this with white uh uh because after rook
captures on g3
rook the g7 check seems like it's the
same thing with the king being even more
active on e4 the problem is after king
to h8 rook captures an h7 check king g8
how do you continue the position now uh
for example king to f4 was played in the
game now we have rook to e3 by alireza
and if you look at this position this is
much much different than this position
that we just discussed where white is
just completely crushing it so after
this rook the e3 move we have rook beat
the g7 czech king to f8 and now rook
back to f7 check king to g8 rook after
g7 check king f8 and now rook to f7
check king to g8 rook h the g7 check
came to h8 and now a rapport goes for
the g6 pawn
but now we have rook to e2 by alireza
uh so here we have pawn to e6 uh trying
to push that pass pawn to victory now
rook to e8 uh adding another attacker to
the e pawn uh and now how do you play
this the the thing is you could try upon
the d3 here and it uh it still works but
it's um uh also incredibly complicated
for example king of three d2 now let's
say uh
you can't play d2 you have to play
something like uh
you know anything but d2 but the problem
is if you try something like this uh
then white always has this three trick
of rook to f8 to check and now you have
problems after rook captures an f8
checking captures on e2 uh rook to d8
we're gonna block with king to d1 and
now white is winning this end game so
that's the problem the although d3 can
be played it's incredibly difficult to
actually play it so just rookie 8 this
is the a much easier way to do it rook
h6 check came to g8 we have rooked the
g6 check and now kink the h8 we have
rook f2f6 uh
not going for the perpetual trying to
create some sort of a
winning position and
it it's actually possible to win this
because here uh alireza plays rook to e7
and it is basically another
one of those moves that is um
the only move that that will lose this
position for him uh just to show you an
example if rook to g8 for example uh
this will this will allow you to draw
the game if rook h6 check we're gonna
play king g7 now we're going to deliver
another check king of f8 and now after
rook captures on g8 king captures we're
gonna play king f5 but now pawn to d3
and let's say rook to h3 we're gonna
play pawn to d2 now rook to d3 putting
the rook behind the pass pawn uh now
king to f8 and if rook to d8 with check
we're just gonna play king to e7 rook d7
check we just repeat king to e8 and now
you can start pushing the pawn to b4 uh
and it seems like white is winning but
white really is not winning king to f8
pawn to b5 you can even push the pawn
all the way king e8 pawn to b6 and now
let's say rook f2 check king to g6 you
just play rook e2 and now you're
threatening this pawn and there's uh no
way to play this if you push b7 again it
seems like you're winning but just real
captures with check king to f5 and now
king captures on d7 b8 queen now you
also get a queen into the game and now
queen b7 check you force the king away
from the defense of the rook uh king
king to d8 doesn't really matter where
the king goes you're gonna capture this
and you are very close to checkmating uh
black but of course now the black queen
starts checking and that there is no
winning this so incredibly complicated
but it uh does not yield more than a
draw however after rook to e7 by alireza
now the position is winning but you have
to play uh
uh
uh the correct idea so you can even try
to spot this one i will give you a
couple of seconds so feel free to pause
the video and try to find it the only
winning move for a rapport while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not playing b4
this is one of the few positions where
b4 is not the winning idea incredible as
it is i know i i was surprised myself
but uh this is the only move that not
the only move but this move does not win
here and it is the one that the rapport
played here the winning move is king to
f5 so congratulations if you were able
to work this out uh it's incredibly
beautiful and incredibly uh wild uh
point is that after uh pawn to d3 which
is our only counter play basically uh
we're going to play rook to g1 now you
play r upon the d2 and now you play rook
to h1 with check king to g8 and now rook
f the h6 that's what you play and now
the point is if um
black tries something like rook that you
want to promote this pawn you just
checkmate the black king that's why king
to fa f5 is so powerful so you will not
be able to play a rook to e1 and without
rook d1 where is your counter play rook
to after you check you're going to play
king here and now after rook to e to
check king to d6 we're gonna attack the
rook here and after rook to h7 trying to
get white to play rook captures on h7
because then rook to e1 is possible uh
we just play rook to g6 again this is
the only winning uh continuation of rook
to g6 and you have to really really find
everything here and after king to h8
rook gta g1 uh now you are uh guarding
the d1 square you're guarding the e1
square the the trade on h1 is always
winning for white uh so let's say rookie
three you're going to play rook captures
on h7 with czech king captures and now
rook to d1 and this will be winning if
you want to see how rook to d3 check
king to e7 king to g6 now we're gonna
push the pawn pawn to b4 and now you uh
will push that pawn to victory you can't
get five you're going to push b5 and now
the king will try to help out with with
this um pawn but it is much too late
upon the b6 we're going to play king to
e3 uh king to f7 now getting ready to
push the e pawn as well king to e2 and
now of course rook captures on d2 that's
how you do it king captures pawn to e7
and now after a few more checks are
given king to e6 rook to e3 check king
to d6 rook to d3 with check king to c5
rook to c3 check king to b4 now you can
play rook to e3 but now b7 will win the
game so incredibly incredibly
complicated rook capture c7 b8 queen
that's how you do it however
it was not played in the game
instead of this king to f5 idea after
this rook the e7 move was played we have
pawn to be for right away by rapport and
now uh alireza can nicely get a draw
here by playing pawn to d3 right away
and it seems like uh can't we just play
king f5 uh
is it really that different yes it is
because after king f5 the pawn is
already on d2 now that's the problem if
rook h6 checking the g8 you do not have
time to double up on the h file like in
the line that we've discussed you're
gonna play rook h1 but not just rookie
one and you are never never ever winning
this so instead after d3 rook the g3 was
played going after the pawn just a d2
biologist rook h6 check rook to h7
blocking and now there's no good way to
continue if you play something like this
the threat in checkmate we just moved
the rook rook to h1 we guard the back
rank
and the the queening square and you you
you have an escape square for your king
so you're not getting checkmated so here
rapper just traded rook captures king
captures and rook to d3 now uh but now
king to g6 yes rapper is still up upon
but alireza uh once upon a time a 2800
player knows how to draw this uh you
know blindfolded uh you know
without a problem talking of three rook
captures on e6 we have rook captures on
d2 and now king to f6 with king f4 now
rook to e1 but now rook to d4
interestingly
uh if you try rook to beat you to start
pushing the pass pawn uh it doesn't
really work king e6 we're gonna play
pawn to b5 king to d7 and after the pawn
is pushed all the way we're going to
block it with the king and the white
king can never cross the e file to help
out with the advancement of the pawn so
this is of course a draw so after this
rook to d4 was played instead by rapport
and alice just played king to e6 and he
was in this position on move 60 that uh
rihanna and alireza furuja agreed to a
draw as there is nothing more to be done
here so incredibly incredible uh start
to the candidates around one and two
both uh rapper to having a an incredibly
wild game in day one against the duda
again with that c5 idea now getting this
wild game against alireza
with
some incredible winning chances but
that's just how complicated and games
are no one knows absolutely everything
about the end games and you know some
you will always miss it doesn't matter
if it's classical or if it's bullet you
you are never going to find everything
uh even even magnus can't spot
everything and this was well at one such
game it's a shame for rapper that it was
in the candidates tournament but
uh i mean that's just end games they are
so incredibly complicated but a good
thing for uh alireza is that he now uh
survives both his first two games with
the black pieces and now we'll see what
he prepared with the white pieces and
can he maybe uh start uh
maybe winning some games of course it's
incredibly hard against everyone but
we'll see what he prepared with white uh
so yeah a great game by both of them it
ends in a draw and uh well uh they are
both uh still alive to fight a fight in
in round three uh so that's the game
hope you guys enjoyed it and if you were
able to spot both pause the video
moments you are truly an incredible
chess player with a with a bright future
ahead of you you know
inches and outside of chess i will i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to levon and i would like to thank andre
andrew lastova johann derek king and
aravind kumar vendeli for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament uh until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day